does AI have you worried about the
future of your career in this video I'm
going to show you that AI isn't going to
replace motion designers anytime soon so
don't worry your job is safe
[Music]
hey there my name is Cameron with motion
science and in this video I'm going to
talk about whether or not AI will
replace motion designers there's a lot
of talk these days about how artificial
intelligence is going to replace human
workers in a variety of Industries and
while it's true that AI is capable of
doing some things better than we can
there are certain areas where humans
will always have the upper hand motion
design is one of those areas here's a
look at how AI can actually help motion
designers become better at the craft
rather than replace them one way that AI
can help motion designers is by
providing inspiration for new projects
for example let's say you're working on
a logo animation for a client you might
start by doing a quick search on Google
Images for logo animations this will
give you a basic idea of what's been
done before and what's possible but what
if you were to explore some new
territory that's where AI comes in once
you enter prompts into AI you never
really know what it's going to spit back
out to you so at every time I enter a
prompt I'm always given new inspiration
because as a designer I have my own
personal experience so my own experience
is instrumental in what I design it's
based on what I have experienced in my
reality so if I've traveled to different
parts of the world or I've seen certain
imagery it's going to influence what my
design looks like that's where AI can
really open up new creative
possibilities because AI doesn't have my
own personal experience so what AI gives
back to me opens up my experience
creating new visuals there are now a
number of AI powered design tools that
can generate endless possibilities for
logo animations or any other type of
motion graphic for that matter all you
need to do is input a few parameters
such as the size the shape the color of
the logo and the AI tool will then do
the rest not only will this save you
hours of brainstorming time but it will
also help you come up with ideas that
you would never have thought of on your
own another way that AI can help motion
designers is by streamline finding the
actual production process for example
there are now tools that can
automatically generate keyframes based
on your input this means that you don't
have to spend hours tweaking each
individual frame by hand the AI tool
will do it for you as someone who works
in motion design I can tell you from
experience that this can be an absolute
Lifesaver when deadlines are tight let
me give you another example let's say
you want to create an animated character
you could spend weeks modeling and
animating it by hand but with the help
of artificial intelligence you could
simply upload a photo of the character
and have it animated for you AI can also
help automate tedious tasks like
rotoscoping I don't know a lot of motion
designers who enjoy rotoscoping and
there are a lot of powerful AI programs
out there who can do the rotoscoping for
you an example of AI being used to
generate new ideas can be seen in this
simple example here so I recently
created a style frame for a fictional TV
series called Black Rose and I needed to
create a title card for it so I wanted
to start with a image as a base and then
work around that image which is
typically how I work and how I did that
with AI is I went in and typed in a
prompt and you can see it started to
generate images now something like this
interesting doesn't work for what I'm
looking for then it generated this image
again interesting and I continued to
make variations of it and continue to
ask AI to Output New images and I could
continue to refine and test things to
create new images so before AI I would
have been searching stock photography
sites to find an image to start with
something like this I probably would
have searched for Rose images which I
then would have cut out and duplicated I
would have searched for field images
maybe poppy fields whatever it is to
create a field here and then I would
have searched for you know castles and
backgrounds and things like that to blur
out and put in the background plus skies
I would have had to composite this
entire image to get gather from multiple
photographs or 3D renders to create this
it would have taken me hours if not days
to do that with AI I can create an image
like this within seconds AI is not going
to replace motion designers anytime soon
in fact AI can actually help us become
better at our craft so if your emotion
is iron don't be afraid to embrace Ai
and use it to your advantage remember
that AI can be your ally not your enemy
I hope that you really enjoy this lesson
as much as I loved teaching it so please
let me know if you have any questions in
the comments below I'd love to answer
them for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it helps other people
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
master the art of style and execute like
a pro I have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is Cameron
and this is motion
[Music]
foreign
[Music]